you
hi everyone it's Jerry this is a round
three game from the 2016 Bilbao masters
final between Magnus Carlsen playing on
the wide end and Sergei Kuryakin this
game will act as a nice preview for
their upcoming battle later this year
November of 2016 where they will compete
in the World Chess Championship match in
New York reigning champion Carlsen
versus challenger Kerry Aachen so let's
see how their game here in July play out
Carlsen opening with e4 karak and
replying with the Sicilian Knight f3 d6
we don't go straight in for an open
Sicilian Carlsen elects to build up that
advance c3 preparing to meet C takes D
with C takes D and forming an ideal pawn
Center Knight f6 efore is not a threat
this is indirectly defended Queen a4
would hit with check and pick up the
night this idea is present for many
moves Bishop e2 g6 castles Bishop g7
white wants to play d4 however playing
d4 would allow black to capture a for
now notice Queen a4 would no longer be
hitting efore directly the D pawn gets
in the way so it's first Bishop e5
Knight c6 and now d4 can be played with
the different ID in mind there's now a
different reason why e for is poison
because white would take advantage of
the pin on a six Bishop d3 both Knights
are hit and one of them will soon be won
so Queen b6 hits the bishop and more
importantly puts pressure on d4 this is
important because White has an ideal
pawn center and allowing them to sit
here controlling all four of these
squares in the black position is too
much black wants some squares to work
with black wants one of these pawns to
move to flinch
a 4c takes T C takes D and now black
gets out of the pin this is now a threat
so we obviously just develop and defend
the pawn right hang on it's important
not to do this it's important to
recognize that black actually has a two
birds for one stone tactic up their
sleeve what am I talking about this
Bishop is ready to take out two key
defenders of d4 if you're not careful
Knight c3 Bishop g4 Bishop takes Knight
Queen takes Knight there's no longer two
defenders for d4 this is going to
collapse there's a big problem a big
accident is soon to happen on d4 if
you're allowing Bishop g4 on this move
10 d4 cannot be maintained like pushes
and the night he goes back home not the
happiest piece in the world but at least
black was successful with making the
white center flinch two squares that are
now available to the black pieces c5 and
e5 Knight c3 only now white is working
with some space a good idea is to look
for some piece exchanges that's what we
have Bishop g4 he's given a kick Bishop
takes Knight Queen takes a couple of
minor pieces have been exchanged black
has a little bit more you know working
with the space disadvantage I'll find it
a little bit easier to operate on the
squares within the black position now
that gets in the ball game white wants
to finish Queen side development I can't
move the bishop just yet though need
some defense of b2 rook a to be one well
that's the only book that could go there
right the rook for the moment defends b2
just to free up that bishop notice if
you're trying to do this to mask the
Queen from seeing b2 well this isn't a
stable
square for the bishop so it's rook to be
one rook F to c8 half completely open
file bishop c2 gets out of any Knight c5
move with tempo and also watches over a
sensitive point in the white position D
395 Queen e2 like is repositioning some
opening up the bishops eyes a little bit
more Bishop g5 throws a punch that
Bishop is kicked away some h6 g5 there's
now no more pressure on e7 but there are
now some gaps in the black position h5
f5 is a little bit more vulnerable now
pawn on g5 not quite a whole but a
little bit more vulnerable
Queen a6 very important moment and we're
nearly at the halfway point in the game
of 19 Queen exchange what do we do
of course we take the Queen's right we
get to double our opponents pawns double
isolated pawns awful right hang on it's
not a good idea to exchange Queens
notice that black will have a lot of
pressure on the Queen side especially
combined with this bishop cutting right
into these dark squares this is not a
good decision because of those reasons
because black would have that Queen side
pressure and maybe more importantly in
the other factor to look out is that
with these advances here it is black who
we can say has a little bit more of a
vulnerable King position so makes sense
to keep the Queen's on the board Queen
d1 rook C form not the only move here a
very logical looking move to you know
post up that rook right in the white
position and prepare to get that last
piece involved another move and maybe a
better move is one that looks to
restrict one of White's ideas namely an
F for pawn break now that this G pawn is
on the fifth rank this is a way to crack
open the Kings side and try to take
advantage of these weaknesses that have
been created on the black King side with
h6 and g5 h5 f5 a little bit more
vulnerable breaking up in position with
f4 is a way to kind of sneak into those
weak points within the black camp
by playing rook to see form there's now
it prepares the doubling on the C file
but at the same time places a certain
restriction on the black pieces both
Knights in fact really can't move as
otherwise we can have a case where the
bishop takes the knight the knight isn't
there to recapture what are we having
Bishop d3 with the skewer this Knight
goes somewhere we have Bishop d3 with
the skewer so this is maybe not a
direction to go in for black pivoting up
on c4 another move another idea here is
to take into account this f4 pawn break
and play Knight to g6 this stays out of
the bishop well it gets out of the
bishops way he can now see directly and
more importantly it looks to control the
f4 break if white really wants to crack
with that 4 you have to invest the dark
square Bishop and I'm not so sure how
good an idea this would really be I
would prefer black here and if white is
not fast enough we could soon see white
under some serious pressure along the G
file and this Bishop here if you
consider him worth 3 points you need to
reconsider he is a beast strong strong
strong piece ok Knight g6 is an
alternative to combat the f4 pawn break
we didn't have that in the game
Brooke c4 instead King H 1 preparing f4
this struck me is a little bit odd this
is you know when I'm going through these
games I question move order you know in
this position why not just play f4
straight away what's what's the big idea
here does it really matter should we put
our King in the corner first and then
play f4 or f4 straight away or does it
really matter well it really matters
there are some details here should you
go straight in for f4 with your King
still on g1 notice there is a move I'm
not saying it's the best move in the
world but notice the different idea
that is our different move that is
available for black rook d4 how great of
an inconvenience is this really I'm not
so sure but it's an additional idea that
black has notice the rook cannot be
captured because Knight f3 is hitting
with check and there goes the Queen so
King H 1 we can say doesn't allow for
rook 2 H 4 to rattle the Queen position
King H 1 after king 2 h 1 we have black
doubling white swinging the back
completely around King H 1 the follow-up
move sure enough F 4 G takes f Bishop
takes F let's consider that wasn't just
any pawn exchange that was the heart of
the black King site structure that was
just exchanged for the the white F pawn
who has the safer King it's white G 2 H
3 structure versus H 6 F 7 structure not
the happiest structure here for black
ken white really take advantage of this
Queen b6 Queen h5 a very active move and
I'd have six Queen f5 staying active on
this f5 post she cannot be kicked from
that Square so easily Queen to d8 Bishop
b3 kicks the rook around a little bit
gets out of the line of fire how
reliable a home can see to really be all
right the knight was pinned to the
bishop for as long as we had that post
rook to d4 Bishop takes Knight pawn
takes and now we have rook B to D 1 this
is blacks best piece I believe white
wants to keep it under control I'm not
so sure white wants to capture the rook
but keeping it under control you know
maybe there's an idea to get into the
second rank
or maybe even some idea of making use of
the third-ranked just for a moment
in order to make some kind of transfer
over towards the Kings side that might
be a very good defensive piece for black
what follows Queen d7 offering a queen
exchange this is declined white wants to
keep Queens on the board better King
position rook to b4 I think there's an
alternative here I'm not really a fan of
to be four I think that this is blacks
best piece and he does well I think the
rook does well to simply sit there even
in some case where let's say the rook is
captured let me just kind of make a pass
and move let's just assume that this
pawn is captured or the rook is captured
and then this Knight is hunted down we
have a case of opposite colored bishops
and also without their spawn on the
square at one at some point maybe the
bishop can find an excellent post on e5
I think the rook should sit is the short
story instead of playing over to b4 as
it played out in the game the rook
turned out to be a little bit off side
from the b4 square that's what was
played I just kind of made a passing
move what would what would have been
better one of the better moves here is
to get on with a five I just made a
dummy move here with a six but something
far more meaningful something far more
meaningful here is a5 now what's the
meaning behind that well notice the how
to say the security the comfort that the
white pieces have the mud the white
minor pieces have on b3 and c3 if there
isn't a good way to improve the quality
of your own pieces an idea is to try and
diminish the quality of your opponent's
pieces a5 is a step in that direction
looking to rattle the bishops position
with a four maybe even B 5 B 4 this is
an idea black should have implemented to
get the queenside pawns rolling in order
to disrupt the white minor pieces in the
game it was rook to b4 rook to d2 is
actually a very aggressive move little
may be difficult to see that it's
aggressive you know he's just coming up
a single rank but there's a strong idea
in mind with this move rook to f8 his
kind of crawling up into a ball this is
freeing up the knight to move right
there's you know he can't he couldn't
move for some time because of the
pressure on the F file another try is to
once again look for these a5 a4 ideas to
disrupt the minor pieces after rikta f8
we now have g4 and these ideas of
pushing the pawns is maybe a thing of
the past
g4 first and maybe you know this rook to
d2 move one may think you're preparing
to triple up on the F file but not so
fast I like this next move g4 white is
looking to dislodge the knight and also
maybe make use of the G file it could be
the F file it could be the G file
playing g4 first keeps those options
open for the rook notice the importance
of the move order here white isn't going
straight in with route 2 f2 first g4 on
the cars is h4 g v a5 now but by this
point it's too late rook g4 Rick G -
excuse me can be played all right
already excuse me and if a 4 is played
at this stage you could actually ignore
that as white playing g5 h takes G rook
takes take the bishop doubled up soon to
be tripled up soon to be checked me
you're not defending this attack so this
is coming a bit too late after rook g2
Knight h7 here come the pawns white is
looking to crack open the black King
position get these pieces working at a
maximum rook b6 here comes g5 King gets
out of the G file very sensible now
doubling on the G file f5 a better
attempt is rook to g6 but even so there
are there are ideas here for white to
even come over to the H file the
computers playing out bishop h4 first I
guess to inconvenience the Queen and
then even operate along the H file if
there's some capture let's say at this
point after Rick - H - if takes this is
just playing into White's hands this
rook is not playing this Bishop is not
playing it's hard to say that the knight
or even the rook is really playing white
is the one who has all the aggressive
pieces and black is just crawling up
into a ball at this point there really
isn't a good defense this would offer
some better defense but even so it would
be a very very difficult road ahead
after the game move f5 we had Queen h3
this pawn is now pinned and soon we're
going to have the G file ripped right
open rook to be for G takes H Bishop
takes H if you're trying to keep this
file closed after Queen h3 suppose h5 we
can have the rook coming over to f1 and
soon this pawn could even be picked up
with the bishop not a good not a good
way to resist this attack either in the
game the G file gets ripped open and
these heavy pieces are very telling
there's already a mate thread on g8
Queen takes rook takes rook takes 4 mate
Knight f6 Queen g6 hits the bishop and
Knight to g4 is there to defend the
bishop but he could just be picked up
rook takes Knight and with that black
resigned what would follow after pawn
takes his queen takes bishop a check
another check and rook takes pawn if you
don't take the rook here you're getting
mated and if you do well you're not
going to be surviving very long anyhow
there isn't really any other move at
this point here instead of the game move
Knight g4 a knight to g8 there's Queen
h5 and soon we're going to be
undermining the black position taking
out the knight and then taking the
bishop Queen d6 there's now rook g6
there's just no saving at this point
it's beyond busted here for black so
interesting game it's nice to see these
guys go at it
they'll be at it again once more in this
Bilbao masters final and fast forward
four months they'll be competing in the
world chess championship match just to
the upper right
feel free to cast your vote who will you
well not your vote but yeah your vote I
could say it like that
who will you be rooting for in the World
Chess Championship match who would you
like to see when feel free to cast your
vote and maybe even check back from time
to time to see what the how others are
viewing this upcoming match so as usual
feel free to comment again cast your
vote who will you be rooting for feel
free to leave any comments in the
comment section below and as usual I
hope you got something out of this video
that's all for now take care bye